all of us and I can certainly I can
certainly speak for most of us but
myself absolutely are in this for the
long haul and we need to get some ducks
in a row to come back to come back as
strongly as we can and when we do we're
going to be raising an army mud clips
for closers last segment this is when we
often kind of wrap this up in a ribbon
for you and I know it's become crowded
closes and I appreciate how how much you
guys have let me you allow me to take
the opportunity to be earnest and talk
with you guys in a way that hopefully
helps a lot of people and when we feel
responsibility in doing that so I need
to kind of start this off before I make
a formal announcement and letting you
know that I am a huge hypocrite which
may not necessarily make sense when you
just out of context but let me kind of
explain how that is the case because
we've recently done some life advice
segments and I've had a dispense
sometimes some some life advice that
that I know I should be practicing that
I haven't been this is going to be right
now my last show through new year hold
on
okay I'm not retiring this is going to
be my last show through new year and
it's specifically due to some health
reasons don't worry I don't have I don't
get cancer or AIDS I can see the real
starting right now
we'll be back though the second week of
January so please bookmark and come back
but health issues medical issues that
require more attention than I can fit
into every other Friday between 11:00
and 2:00 p.m. which is literally have to
pick every other Friday because like
people don't realize you know we don't
have 40 staff members of The Young Turks
um so if we're gon do want to change my
mind or if we're gon doing a show on
campus we have to travel back that's the
whole team yeah it's everybody all the
time everybody all the times you that's
a B that's Madison that's everybody
right pretty in particularly myself
sometimes people get stay home I have to
be there as always you know I'm not
complaining but timewise I literally
have to so what we've tried to do is
actually this is to give you an idea to
the inner workings here we do what we
call a super video we tape it often on
the weekends or we tape one week and
then the next week it's like okay
we still have to work an insane amount
but I find a window to a
I picked the dentist this week or going
to a doctor or whatever it is a
Rheumatologist any I listened a lot of
people probably you know I've talked to
on air quite a bit about having kind of
thyroid issues and being I was diagnosed
with fibromyalgia a year and a half ago
I didn't really take it super seriously
but nothing I'm not going away
but yeah auto auto immune related to the
point of I had a doctor recently kind of
sit me down and say listen you're not
gonna you know make it very long not
because of a cancer they said because
the stress and how it's affecting kind
of this I hate to use these serious
words because I don't want to be overly
dramatic we're coming back the second
week of January something for several
other reasons gonna be a lot of big
developments happening but a doctor
actually looked me in the eye said
listen the disease state unless you
correct it progresses says some progress
fast I've seen people hit cancer and
they go in three months and someone had
it for several years and they've been
fine so but unless corrected what you
have is progressively getting worse you
are progressively doing damage to your
body and unless you correct it it's
going to get worse and sometimes it goes
around the bend where then it becomes
something permanent that you now you're
trying to correct it retro actively in
post as we would say in this program as
opposed to fixing it live we'll do it
live so makes make no mistake this is
one thing I know a lot of people talking
I've seen a lot of people talk about
YouTube burnout this is not you - it's
like oh how oh my god you mean you have
to talk to a camera well people give you
65 thousand a month on on patreon oh
what a freaking nightmare right like I
thought this that's not what this is
this is not an I'm burnt out and I don't
want to do any more though I am
exhausted it's not it's it that there is
nothing else I could dream of doing
outside of this there's nothing else as
I wanted to and right now I am less and
less capable of performing of being able
to do what it is it not only is
important to me what are the only thing
that I can do but what it is it's so
important to too many other people who
watch this we just hit three million
subscribers and I cannot thank you
enough thank you so much everyone to
join Mulla please please don't don't
stop mug club or cancel your memberships
because we're gone for a little bit
we're gonna come back we're always
trying to think of a ways to add value
and I
we have a million ideas that we've not
been able to implement because of all
the things that we have to do
simultaneously and I'll get into a
second but we just hit three million
subscribers and it's because of you and
it's because we're gunning for more
growth we're gunning to reach more
people that I do need to get healthy and
it's this isn't just myself everyone
here has a very significant workload not
only just quarterblack and an engineer
Abbi and everyone there in the control
room everyone here works really really
hard to even idea this has been going on
for a while every day performing for the
last I would say well that's been going
for a while but the last four or five
months every day performing doing this
show is for me has been worse than the
day before it in in in my ability it's
almost like it's like and again it's not
that I don't we don't want to do this
that we know we have to this we know how
important is it's like still being able
to look at the finish line and your legs
don't work and you're not able to get
there that's how it's been feeling every
single day for a while now but it's it's
kind of like the nickel circling the
drain the last few months where it's
gotten really really hard to to think to
physically recover my body doesn't heal
we I will have an end up like a it's
like 20 years where I'll have a shoulder
injury and I'm like I don't know how I
hurt my shoulder and now it hurts worse
two weeks ago I'm so grateful I was so
grateful not only the people who make
this this show possible and give us all
the desire to be back and ready to go
but for a team here who really for the
first time have been encouraging me to
get healthy and to do what I need to do
so during this break not only we're
moving to a new space to give an idea
and not like last time where we
primarily moved into more space for
storage but now more space for
production for new programs were
dramatically increasing staff this is
all going to be happening before the
second week of January dramatically
increasing staff dramatically increasing
budget and research capabilities
Owen filled in for me yesterday yeah
that wasn't an accident many of you
enjoyed it I would like to see what a
show with Owen is like when he doesn't
have to scramble when he don't have to
worry about the YouTube guys when he has
protection under the umbrella of my
half-asian lawyer bill Richman when
we're able to actually offer some
resources here to let Owen do what he
and we might have some announcements
regarding Owen coming to mug club who
knows we're still working it out you
know he'll be here in third chair much
more often anyway but there are a lot of
ideas that we've had to want to increase
value for people out there because we
live we eat sleep and breathe mutt club
we really do I know it sounds silly this
is a token it's it's I mean what's
wonderful is hand etched it's currency
but it doesn't mean that what it does is
it what it means is what it symbolizes
and it symbolizes the ability for
everyone here to make a living the
ability not only for anyone here to make
a living but when people are getting
shut down or seeing these false
copyright violations and yet listen we
work really really hard but we have much
more peace of mind because we are not
beholden to the evil censoring overlords
who deny the Armenian Genocide or their
funding caliphates we don't have to
worry about that because of the people
who support this program and it's
because of the people who support this
program it's because of how much you
mean to us that I've got to fix that I
haven't be able to carry out the program
to the best of my abilities because of
not only the workload but my diminished
capacity let me tell you some it's been
extremely humbling to get to the
vulnerable side here it's been extremely
humbling to just kind of have to accept
I'm only 31 but um you know people have
talked about you gave you see these
people always and you're like I'm going
off the grid but you're always off the
grid
I haven't taken an actual a week off in
over half a decade and I know you've
seen well we've had two weeks Raymond
done shows but you know when that
happens it's like no that's because no
that we have to do a whole studio update
we're painting the whole green-screen
area a week let alone enough time to
really I need to travel now and see some
specialists but I used to be able to do
it I think we're kind of hits that point
really why am I so what is happening I
used to be able to do all of this I used
people go 16-hour days with not so much
as a day off and and now just every it's
humbling to kind of have to accept okay
these are the things that I can do this
is what I'm not capable of doing at this
stage of my life especially if I want to
you know get get healthy and like it
many of you ask hey you having kids
hopefully eventually but what I really
hope is that not only do you continue to
support it's not myself but everyone who
works to make this this show it happened
and let me kind of leave you with this
if it if
help so I want to wish you by the way
everyone a Merry Christmas and thanks
not only the Moka but a wonderful
sponsor Walter let me tell you something
about Walter by the way why does it mean
so much to us we and will be will have
some more sponsors we've had we've had
people line up out the door particularly
around Christmastime wanting to sponsor
the show but we also know that we're not
able to just talk it would change the
show if we tossed in 15 live Reed's for
random sponsors that were rotating we
wouldn't actually able to shoot
commercial series we want to get back to
shooting more creative commercials we
haven't had the ability to do that
because we've been a little bit
underwater with some of the migration
you know trying to trying to staff move
to a new place get new technology up and
working while doing a daily show it's
just not really been feasible but um
Walter has allowed us because they've
step up stepped up and they said you
know what we want to be in every show we
wants to do naming rights there are a
ton of great firearms out you can like
Glock you can like gage okay you can
like SIG's sake I'm trying to think of
who else out there would be I don't know
I don't know I can't even think right
now but the point is do you like
Mercedes do you like BMW they're good
cars right
I prefer Walther not not just because we
we we were seeking them out for a long
time because I liked their firearms but
they have the balls to support this show
they have the balls to step up and say
hey it's a controversial show while
other companies like Smith & Wesson or
rigueur whoever it is are incorporating
trigger locks because they want to catch
up to the gun lobby we're not gonna do
it we have never done anything where
Walther has said no that's too
controversial ego oh man we love we love
what you're doing and thank you so much
for helping to support our company so
not only what you guys do with with
mukla but Walter listen if you're gonna
go and purchase a firearm we don't
really have a big sell it's just try the
Walther and see what you think
I've never had anyone tried Google
Walther PPQ review this is a ppq so
become google Walther PPQ
see how many pages it takes you to find
anything other than a glowing review
about it being the best kept secret so
it really is an incredible feeling to be
sponsored by companies and to it's not
that they sponsor the show it's the
faith that they place in the show where
we don't we don't even have to say these
were our numbers this week or this is
how many live reads you when we call
Walter they say thank you
you got it we're grateful for this
partnership and we're so grateful for
the partnership with them and we
appreciate you guys supporting them
there really been some great this
here's some unbelievable relationships
that I've been created and I want to say
one thing to this is also we have such
an amazing team here we're building up
this kind of a team behind the scenes
where I want to make sure that I'm able
to give them my best not only you my
best but the people who put all their
blood sweat and tears into making this
show possible
you wonder why there are no overlays
where there are so few sources and shows
like The Young Turks or most other
conservative programs honestly but all
the leftist programs that I can think of
outside of John Oliver he does provide
some sources Samantha bee we won't
include because Slade should not be
chief among some it's because it takes
work it's a lot more work to actually
bring these up so you guys are able to
look up the references it's it's a lot
it's a lot to mention doing doing
sketches and photo shops these people
who are unbelievably skilled behind the
scenes it's a lot more work that's why
most people don't do it so I want to
make sure I do right by them final thing
I want to say is this this temporary
break again we'll be back January 2nd is
not because any of us to really not want
to go away it is precisely because all
of us and I can certainly I can
certainly speak for most of us but
myself absolutely are in this for the
long haul and we need to get some ducks
in a row to come back to come back as
strongly as we can and when we do we're
going to be raising an army and I hope
that you're a part of it Merry Christmas
if we don't see a follow me on Instagram
a lot of Crowder's Instagram I haven't
been verified yet and you'll be able to
watch maybe some of the recovery that's
going on and and if you want to get
involved in some of the person which I
don't know why you do but apparently
that's what kids are doing on the
Instagram these days I love you I
appreciate you so much don't forget
about my club when you're buying gifts
and oh my god January's gonna be it's
gonna be a rough ride for there not you
subscribe watch one of these other
videos or hit the notification bell well
you should hit that if you subscribe
anyways because subscriptions don't mean
anything on YouTube anymore now you have
to get notifications and it shows up in
your inbox so I don't know why you
subscribe in the first place but that's
we have to do also we're not making
money off these videos anymore because
YouTube decided why they just said we're
not going to and when we said why they
didn't tell us why exactly imagine if
you showed up to your job to do your
work and then they said hey by the way
we're not gonna pay you said why they
said piss off